last time i spoke to you
you were ready to get married you were
gonna propose
and here we are what two three years
later no proposal no marriage
uh
should i be concerned what's the update
on this it's funny we were talking about
this yesterday i was like oh he's
probably gonna ask like
because we talked about this last time
and it was big you were gonna propose
you know dylan dylan your girlfriend you
were gonna propose i was all for it
we're totally gonna do it like i um
i wanted to be proposed to
so i think i i very distinctly carved
out my um
what i wanted and you know she she
nailed it it was really cute she did
very well and we're totally we're we're
we're marrying it's happening you had a
spell out for her what you wanted in a
proposal no i think i felt a little bit
like it was so clear that i had already
like i basically did it i blew my load
on howard stern
and then basically was like well now
it's your turn i don't know i kind of
did it you know what i mean like and i
know i wasn't specific at all it was
just like it's not a given that i would
be the one you know and i mean like with
two girls you never know like who's
gonna fulfill like what weird [ __ ]
gender role thing and we don't do that
or think about it in those terms so i
was like wait well i'm not the one for
sure
and so
i was like kind of joking for a bit like
no i want to be the one to pro like i
want to be proposed to and then she just
grabbed that bowl and made it happen it
was [ __ ] so cute yeah
this is so romantic
so now you're engaged
and there will be a wedding i know i'm
not going to be invited to the wedding
i'm sure of that i mean i don't know you
guys well enough but are we having a big
wedding what are the plans give me
something i want to stay home like i
want to be in la so everyone can come
and
you know i want us to be pretty chill
like i don't want anyone walking anyone
down any aisles like we're just gonna
like stand and like do vows and [ __ ]
party after like it's it's it's kind of
just a great excuse to like get together
and like say i love you in front of all
your friends
we would love to be friends with you
like this is you
know full standing offer come to the
wedding like oh i would go we welcome
you i want to see it you would yes i
want to see what you're going to wear i
want to see what the food is i mean
what are you going to do are you going
to wear a traditional wedding dress i
want to wear like the best pair of
levi's ever and like
like an old t-shirt that has a tuxedo
printed on it but like cut off and
barefoot and like you know i'm going to
get married and like to paint that like
i want to be chilling i want it to be
very calmy
i want to see her laugh hysterically
when she sees me in like a faux tuxedo
t-shirt and we got to have somebody
marry you at prominence who could we get
we're either going to have like no one
we're just going to do it ourselves and
just like not have somebody officiate to
sort of like
have another party involved in like our
moment but we did hear that guy here
from the food network officiates a lot
of gay weddings and so the idea
of that man that sweet sweet
spiky-headed man coming to our wedding
and officiate it just makes me laugh so
much what about
um
a band uh no you need like the hits you
need to play princess die ballads you
need to go like full on like wedding
music i love the idea of like a band
maybe for like the ceremony and like the
first kickoff but music like you want to
dance you should have like uh an ed
sheeran or somebody to do one or two
songs at the wedding some key rock and
roll friend of yours i think it's a
great idea maybe i mean who knows maybe
it'll be the first time i ever get to
meet mick if he wants to come to the
wedding
stones perform at your wedding i love it
just be beautiful